by regarding addiction as an illness by
offering treatment instead of a more
punitive approach we can take weekly we
can prevent people from committing
tracked crimes just personally I was a
criminal when I was a drug addict by
virtue of my addiction and the ways that
I had to acquire money to get drugs
anecdotally [ __ ] was an armed robber in
and out of Nick all the time hope you
don't mind me telling them this and like
and other people I've met
yeah like criminality is a necessary
component now of course we're not saying
forget the victims but I'm saying it's
better to address the social situation
pragmatically and I think we all know
this but I subscribe prescribing
methadone to people most people want
methadone are using illegal drugs to
supplement their habit they're not
addressing the root problems we need to
approach that we need to approach the
victims with respect where there is
being criminal behavior it needs to be
dealt with correctly but perhaps within
the penal system itself we can offer
treatment to addicts like the brilliant
work was done by wrapped in various
institutions and prisons that Fela needs
to be a carrot or a stick most of those
things in that bizarre meta force I
think what they need to be is love and
compassion so everybody involved you
need to give people to come in criminal
behavior then it needs to be there with
legally but you need to offer them
treatment not simply out some airy-fairy
that's all hold hands and hug liberalism
but because it deals with the problem
and it prevents further crimes being
committed addicts that get clean at one
day at a time through abstinence based
recovery generally speaking stop
committing crimes that's better for
victims it's better for the addict is
better for society